talk closer into the mic why
good good perfect oh yeah am i too far
i never have a mic i know i i know i
always yelling at them
yeah
so when you were um
came to america there was a lot of
racism
i think so yeah yeah but that's the only
one i uh experienced
you know maybe
when i speak a little more english yeah
maybe you know they offered me because i
speak english yeah
but what was because you you're a single
woman in america back in the late 60s in
america
you could have you could have dated a
white guy mom no because i met your
daddy
same year oh the same year you came here
yeah oh
i did
oh your father passed it always i can
say this you know i met one man you know
[ __ ]
wait let me just say something when you
came to america you met dad and you also
told people before you met dad you met
another good-looking man
yeah yeah yeah daddy you're like a
korean guy or a white guy
oh
you never had white dick that ma no i'd
never see one you never seen a white
dick before
oh [ __ ]
have you want to see his
no uh
uh
uh wider than my husband yeah you know
hon honestly mom and i i i i know listen
i never lie i know you don't lie and
you're an honest person you're truth
teller and that's what i love about you
and i love the fact that you know i know
that dad
dying was traumatic and disastrous for
us
but you know what the the good part is
is that you know this is the first time
i think you've ever visited us this in
this way ever never yeah you were able
to come out here right for eight years
yeah and you never were able to maybe
for after 50 years yeah because you know
i never been out of his sight yeah he
always watched what i'm doing are we
candy ma
i don't eat that that's too sweet i i
like it's you know hard one yeah
yeah this is just like huangos oh my god
he's bigger than that
you think so yeah so so when you came
here um in the 60s 1968 oh my god wow
nobody in the people you born before
anyone in this room was born
i was born in 1968
and then so you met dad and then once
you
started dating dad you never saw anybody
else then never i never cheated him
so you've only seen it for 50 years one
gochu then
no it's three you saw three penis oh
yeah yes
blood penis blood penis blood penis you
have to say that we never say that in
words you know what we say go to go to
yeah
if you're listening right now when i say
go to uh-huh that means dick
in korean
because
you like this it's a pepper oh
so whenever somebody say go to that
means they know that then means that
but we don't say it so what is the real
word for penis then i don't know you
don't know
they never learned that no they didn't
have a teacher they never taught you the
word real world
interesting what's the word they use for
a vagina then i know but i just what is
it
i'm not going to say that
we'll cut it out they have a a city in
somewhere
boise
idaho
what's there we don't if we don't say
that because it's just similar to
whatever you asking
similar to the word is yes
you know i look innocent but i know
everything yeah about men and women i
know you do i know i know
i watch a lot of drummers i know you do
yeah oh okay but i wanted to say i'm
sorry what you've been going through and
it's been really hard for us oh yeah
we're whole family i know
how you been feeling
i feel a lot better since i came here
i'm not this room i mean came to l.a
yeah you know i you know like free women
now you know yeah
because you're in phoenix by yourself
i'm not lonely i know but still
i have to text you every night how can i
belong you know i have to text him every
night every night and what he uh respond
nothing
so i asked him should i stop texting you
he goes no mom i enjoy it but he never
answered to me yeah at least stupid say
mom i love you
well once he say mama i love you and he
said what's up you know but i really
don't know what job means yeah and i
asked stephen you know uh your brother
say what so what what what should i you
know uh
tell them i tell him he goes mom that's
just asking you don't have to say
nothing
all right yeah what's up it's just hi hi
what's going going on you know in my
mind i really don't understand what's
what's up means yeah
get up
oh yeah yeah yeah
it doesn't make any sense you know i
don't what's up yeah like yeah yeah
what's up get up
yeah
i've just been having a hard time mom
what spanish
mama what was that
i speak
yeah wow
you've got all these skills that i'm not
even aware of i have you know in my
kitchen
i have all the about uh english yeah
spanish chinese
chinese japanese oh and korean you know
oh she wants you want to learn japanese
i bought up my
niece
bought a book from sent to me here i
never opened the books once i open it
and i didn't have a time yeah so i
didn't study yet mm-hmm but i have a
book but you said you want to do you
want to learn the guitar again i i
registered and i have to cancel every
lesson because i come here i have to
come here oh
[Music]
yeah
george speaks spanish
when i talking be quiet okay why i
learned foreign language why now i'm
asking you why do i learn
foreign foreign language i don't know
why
answer me i ain't gonna i don't know i
just answered you don't yelling and
answering me i don't know no because i
don't want to have a chimer
uh yeah that's why i started taking uh
you know guitar yeah because you didn't
buy piano for me you know every time i
ask him can you buy piano for me no
computer but not piano computer and a
house i know i say piano what a [ __ ]
piano too lady what the [ __ ] yeah don't
say a [ __ ] all right sorry what the dang
yeah
he didn't buy piano for me yeah yeah and
i don't want to pay myself
but he's always say mom you want to have
a new computer i say it's the same price
so i didn't hear asking me by piano you
know so i that's why i'm taking cause
i'm not gonna give you a [ __ ] piano
because you're not gonna use it no no i
practice you're not gonna prac we had a
piano in our house growing up for 40 i
know but i'm not one time did i ever see
you on it because when you went to
school i practiced myself
and i don't know showing off oh i'm very
appropriate i like it
yeah i'm sorry you're so you are yeah my
bad yeah yeah because you know i
practice seven hours a day it's not good
enough
wow wow bringing heat yeah and i know
all the theories you know you know all
the guitar theories are yeah yeah piano
same same theories yeah yeah okay i'm
sorry for questioning you that i'll
forgive you okay thank you
you're my mom thank you amazing
you know the song oh my god i know a lot
of songs yeah but don't ask me singing
you know yeah
well i'm sorry ma i love you so much and
i um
why are you hurting about that no no i'm
just in general i just feel sorry for
what we're going through but every
a whole family going through the same
thing
right yeah i don't think i'm processing
it right though no you are a little bit
late and i mean you are going slow
like steve and i we look at our in eyes
you know and then we start crying
even now we starting looking eyes and if
i like watery eyes he started crying but
he never saw his emotions you know
don't bother up you gotta get it out i i
i honestly i don't know what's going on
i i think about it every night i think i
and i i sit i'll sit down at the edge of
the bed and analyze
what like what what am i feeling what is
why am i fighting i just don't know
i've never been here before i don't know
how to feel
i don't know
that's my first husband i lost yeah so
how do i feel you know i didn't know
that's why
you know right after he to death i first
cried because you know i didn't expect
that you know i thought he i realized he
never to come back to me
you know
that's how we go through all together
yeah yeah
yeah it's been hard yeah well i mean we
had up and downs you know one time i
hate him i'm gonna divorce him after
kids growing up you know but then
you guys growing up wow he treated me so
nicely yeah so
i just didn't divorce him and we live up
to here you know yeah
yeah i mean i think that um
when we the kids moved out of the house
it got better for my mom because he
relaxed more maybe no pressure the
pressure all the discipline i do you
know all the education i he didn't do
nothing he's just making money yeah yeah
but everything else
even moving
i have to take everything even little
items
he just you know come in a new house
yeah yeah say hello you know that's what
i did for this that's what she's doing
now i'm sorry
same thing
for my dad not me yeah you know yeah get
it done babe
fyi get it done
because i my tolerance uh
yeah
oh so he did that too yeah every time
i that's my job and raising kids today
that's my job cleaning the house that's
my job no i hired the cleaning lady yeah
yeah yeah yeah but then but i got a
watcher to do it you know yeah so
uh and he never involved any school you
know
your curricular activities no because i
followed them you know like tennis
tennis and
soccer and
soap the ball and what is even wrestling
we never [ __ ] played softball um
taekwondo we never [ __ ] played
softball mom
wrestling and oh yeah that's a big thing
for me
i love you that was weird
because it's bonded that's nice no
because i
look like him i watch his movie like 10
years ago
know but he's a lot older twice older
than him oh he's twice also in the
future
i think he's all
are you in your 20s right or
30
30 yeah maybe we might have to show him
my mom the video
no don't
i just want to show her what she'll be
disappointed she'll be disappointed in
me i wasn't scared i wasn't scared he
used to be really fat like this oh good
used to be really fast
but there's a video of him singing
that's what i have to do i have to lose
weight yeah yeah you don't
know by looking at it but when you wait
it's a lot heavier yeah
so i'm
having a once a day meal yeah so i have
a lot you know intermittent fasting wow
your body is kind of squarish now it's
weird what it's a good or a bed it's
like spongebob like yellow and squash
good good okay thank you yeah
good job you called your mom spongebob
that's good i don't like spongebob why
he's a square i know
i don't know
i'm like s you're like yeah yeah yeah i
know
[Applause]
yeah
it's so it's you know it's it's funny to
see what i got from my parents though
you know because my mom and my dad
are completely different completely
polar opposites like my mom's more
art
music movies even mute movies and you
know even how
toilet paper yeah i go under he go up
yeah you know i go under too i no you
going up eyes uh what i didn't put that
oh he did he did oh she was watching
that like he's dead then yeah wow i go
under it makes more tips the more easier
yeah
when you wipe your tonka mark
but when you go to the bathroom right do
you wipe
um back to front or front to back when i
was a skinny bag
but when i get set down oh so you go
front you wipe this way i shut up
[Laughter]
that's weird
you don't even know what direction is
the correct thing right what is the
correct direction front to back
yeah yeah all right don't get what are
you angry about i'm not angry because
she's weird sassy all of a sudden you
don't get to ask us about it i know
you're wrong you're all right you never
ask mom those kind of dirty questions
yeah
we're just talking about beautiful
things you know yeah
you know the one memory that i have that
i feel bad about me about you and i what
is that one time you picked me up from
camp
mm-hmm yeah you pushed me i pushed you
yeah i picked oh my god now he's trying
to hug him
he's pushing me away wait so you drop
them off no no what happened was i so i
went to a yeah a summer camp yeah where
they picked us up in a yellow boss took
us into the forest
for a month and came back essentially
yeah then i said hi yeah yeah so all the
kids are like getting off of the bus
and i was on the bus i remember thinking
and people were kids were hugging their
parents but some cool kids weren't
they were like hey mom
right and getting in the car and that's
what i wanted to do
but my mom wanted to do cry cry cry
mouth kisses and the whole thing
it's why i pushed her
and when i did that it broke i could see
it breaking her heart
you know what i mean
[ __ ] shut up
my turn yeah go ahead yeah because
i may i always when i go to his school
stevens i always put on makeups
so look better you know oh you did that
for us yeah oh
because i don't want you to push me like
that i'm very i'm sorry i'm sorry i uh
oh i'm sorry i'll never i never i feel
bad about it that's why i brought it up
i feel bad i'm sorry she didn't do that
i'm never gonna do that again never i'll
never push you out he's trying to hug
him yeah yeah yeah yeah i appreciate it
[Laughter]
and then just you know you dealing with
i mean just the whole life i know the
whole thing the whole thing is
um
it's beautiful though isn't it beautiful
what life
[Laughter]
but like when i look at you know like my
uh
switzerland
your past test yes it wasn't so bad
i thought i grew up very poor yeah but
when i look at all over the world
i wasn't that bad you know yeah and i
thought i'm very because my friend
called me peanuts i'm so small
and my face were your friends called you
peanuts that was the nickname peanut
pizza yeah
you're small
smallest in the class
not now i'm kind of you know you're
small no
not with korean religions no i'm not
music
i'm i'm regular
yeah almond yeah yeah but then you know
and i thought i wasn't pretty but daddy
loves me you know oh mom if i i posted a
photo of you as a young woman once
pretty hard and very internet went
insane i'm not kidding you side leg
she's so uh your mom back in the day you
were very pretty back then serious wow
that's why daddy got so jealous of me
right yeah
i was pretty until 50 years old right i
get bad after 60 years old yeah yeah i'm
not gonna tell my age right now i know
i'm over 70. you know under 80.
just middle of it i'm not
yeah yeah
good so you know what mom from from now
on for the rest gonna be good admit good
to me right
that's you you gotta
you know everybody say you are the best
sunday ever known really my oh my sister
gets jealous of it see you [ __ ]
in this room you guys think that i'm a
tyrant no he's in that [ __ ] it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah he's a [ __ ] head mom
oh my god
i'll buy you a piano okay
yeah get your piano that's it
you're gonna get her a piano yeah of
course
only seven thousand dollars
can we go chat
no never
no i like i love quite top quality you
know that's where you get that from top
quality is that right yeah so
that's
another thing that i get from her which
is everything pick best we want the best
food whatever she thinks the best is
yeah at that time at the time right i
had that same thing which is weird
what
you know he
last month he came on right yes because
of his daddy he bought a shoes
you know
it's a green shoes oh no no
you know so i brought with me
when i brought my husband remains
so i gave to him he said mom i'm not
gonna wear
then why did they buy
you know i think that he pays so much
money you know so she saw you know
yeah yeah where is it i he she gave it
to me the blue conversation oh i
no i would oh i got that from you never
rude uh weird [ __ ] i know but then my
brother got um
my dad yeah
yeah
right he's quiet sometimes serious
temper yeah but that
innocent [ __ ] that he does you know that
kid thing that he does i think he gets
that from you digging from nose
i was just like taking them or eating
these boogers i saw once
once you saw steve eat his boogers once
no
who
[Laughter]
you no never my ear wax when i was
younger you eat when i was younger yeah
yeah yeah that's worse
have you when's the last time you eat
your burger i never eat burgers not one
time
i don't remember you pause for a second
no i don't remember as a kid yeah as a
kid okay you don't you you've never done
it so what what would you guess no i
like i didn't dig but i never eat all
right we were not that poor you know all
right
oh it's
[Laughter]
yeah
we're not poor we're not poor we're not
dead poor yeah i never just i've never
heard that before
i never have hungry people eating their
boogers
no i never eat it i know i've never
heard that though i know i know okay
first i've ever heard
so you're going to come out here more
often then huh
uh do you mind i love it
don't you don't like it of course not
anytime i know you're going to say that
but
i mean true you know true direction but
we hang out way more than you hang out
that's why i want i think you're tired
of me no i'm not tired i have a lot of
energy don't raise your voice as i say
i'll be disrespectful
okay no i think we everyone loves you
mom
no they you know it doesn't mean they do
they do yeah because i'm you i mean so i
brought so i brought my mom so the other
night when she caught into town it was
like two in the morning yeah and i go
comment one in the morning i go let's go
to the comedy store i said okay
nobody there you say i said there's
nobody that's late but there was a lot
of people like today you say i don't
have to say nothing so i came yeah
and i look nice
i talk to you more than you do
together you know well that was a trick
you know that
so we were walking around and
she there's two people that she did a
head to toe like analyzing before she
even said anything
one guy she walks by i go this is my mom
and my mom looks and goes your face is
so interesting
jeff ross
[Laughter]
right then another guy stands up right
you know
this is mrs lee hi
and walked up and she couldn't even get
the words out to say hello because she
didn't know what she was looking at tony
hinchcliffe
she was looking at his body like this is
so skinny he's very skinny and weird
looking yeah but she was a hit there
and um
it's been um
i'm so glad you came out mom it was very
good tell them i'll tell you know uh he
said he knows your 28 year years
what i said to him 20 years 28 oh jeff
and i i told him i know him 48 years oh
that's like a big laugh on him
right yeah yeah
and then i said that later when you said
about jeff and i said that he had hiv
you said should i wash my hands
no i it's not content
no i didn't say that
don't make up story like that
um talk about now now
kalala's turn yeah no no no i like
hearing you guys as well because you
don't wanna talk i know what you're
talking
we had a good time today yeah in the
swimming pool we had we went yeah
downtown and we went swimming together
and we'd like uh you know tell each
other all our stories and snow we are
not gonna we are not gonna tell you and
then we listed all the guys that we
found attractive yeah ellen de long
warren beatty
elvis presley elvis presley
gregory peck uh-huh who else did we like
you didn't really like paul newman a lot
that's he's not my okay i'm going to say
paul newman
was the sexiest man ever to live well
maybe some of them but not to me yeah
who do you think appa you think dad is
sexy
yeah he's you know dark face
and he's kind of a you know not poor but
you know my size yeah yeah perfect for
me
yeah and then we were talking about the
idols of korea bts bts i love oh he
hated exo exo's and we were talking
shiny you know and we were talking about
how like how they manufacture a lot of
these boy bands and after if they don't
make it like there's a high rate of
suicide yeah oh my god you know one of
the shiny boys yeah he suicided like two
years ago no then the exo boy too right
yeah yeah
oh they are famous yeah before bts they
were more famous what band did i know
the guy henry lau what was he in
i don't know they go they
recycle it recycle them yeah fast
because i did a movie with a with a with
a korean um pop star what who else henry
lao
is
he's a super junior from canada that's
him
chinese that's my buddy yeah
so henry lau
because he's a fire fighter
he's from canada yeah so when i went
when i went to thailand to do the movie
with him
he had hundreds of women
girls sleeping in tents outside his
hotel really yeah
yeah so um
i don't know he's just so innocent i
know so like baby face baby face yeah
look your son's famous with henry that's
me and henry
up there to the right
yeah
look
to the right
oh mata yeah that's him and that's me
yeah yeah
he's one of the best and he graduated
from berkeley music
i know i know him and he was in korean
like a borite show
yeah i know um i do
i know what him i said i i have the
photo with him i know him but you don't
know everything i know that's true yeah
that's true ask me time do you want to
do an unhelpful yeah can i ask her one
question really yeah go ahead where if
you can travel anywhere in the world
right now where do you want to go korea
after korea because you've been oh
uh
i know arizona uh no england
because you like the british yeah i love
harry styles yeah like harry potters
you love harry potter with the
what that's what it is lord of the rings
the ring of the hell yeah lord of the
rings and then where you at with a game
of thrones second season or second
season episode i'm gonna watch seven and
who are your favorites the little guy
dinklage uh oh um tyrion uh-huh you know
dead you know
yeah
and then i know i didn't like him first
yeah but as i watch it yeah he's small
but he's very intelligent and smart yeah
and he kind of control his sister who's
a queen yeah i like that yeah do you
like your sister
no i like that
little man what about um
josh oh snow you like king joffrey
joffrey no the king the kid
little not a little the blonde kid you
like him i don't like it yeah he's bad
bad yeah yeah yeah but i like this snow
uh snow best dad yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i love you and that girl dragon's mother
yeah yeah i like her you love her i
usually don't like girls but klyla and
straw other girls i like
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i have to include it in her
because i'm going to go house today
and she's going to take me to airport
yeah or else you don't have a ride here
right i have to walk to burbank
yeah
at the end of the shows we do a thing
called um singing no
we could change it to singing you want
to sing it no but you don't understand i
know i don't understand anything
it's accordion you know the song that
you're gonna say one
because he's the
uh number one handsome boy but he's not
the one who speaks english right oh
that's namjoon that's not
a
monster oh i don't know who you're
talking about the guy with the really
good the best voice
yeah like a sorry yeah yeah he's good
looking yeah i mean he's ideal for me
for boys looking
but we need maybe get older here
yeah yeah him yeah but the thing is is
here's the thing i hate about korean me
that that whole thing is
is that the makeup
oh i'm sorry no it's not that it's just
that it's not based on it's like looks
has so much to do with it yeah we love
it i know but what i'm saying is that i
love it i understand that but there are
singer and singers out there and
songwriters out there they're good they
aren't good looking that never get a
shot in korea too bad
i don't control that i know but what i'm
saying is i don't consider korean things
i just i know you don't control the
korean things they have composer too
they make music they write it i know and
yes if you if bobby and steve were to
have lived in korea what do you think
they're like
never have a chance in korea to grow up
what do you mean i wouldn't survive
no because you don't want to you don't
want to go to college
korea it's the end of the world you know
you got to go to good college but even i
like you know push you you're going to
go other way maybe you know you think
that he would have made why are you so
quick i'm an actress
you know what you are
why you look at me like that you know
that's strange what you know you don't
like to study you know how how much i
pushed you i know i wanted to go to the
house
is that if steve and i grew up in korea
that we would have survived you couldn't
we would died no not died you know i
mean you know what survive means you
know like you if you don't go to college
or something how you
i'm not special i'm not special no i was
i no what i did was that
if you are my son you are special okay
okay
oh my god
so we do at the end a thing called
unhelpful advice and basically people
ask us questions and we give them help
what help you'll see
okay on helpful advice with bobby kelly
and gd lee
uh reading some of these questions i
think there's an overall